you look tired  more dreams  june is very rich it's an adventure  movie it's a coming-of-age movie here's  a story that has to do with first love  and the confirmation of desire  do you often dream things that happen  just as you dreamed them yes paul has  been having these visions of johnny i  know you  she's skeptical she doesn't know who  this person is one day  the legend will be born  i love timothy he's become one of my  closest and dearest friends  i was just so grateful when she showed  up in jordan and she was someone i had a  lot of admiration for  [Music]  she would be paul's right arm  you need to face your fears  is only the beginning  [Music]  you